so let's spend just a few minutes on
Donald Trump and then we're going to
move on to Bobby Kennedy Jr and other
candidates as you can see this 2024 race
is really filling out where we're
talking about Chris Christie and Ron
DeSantis and Bobby Kennedy Biden and
Trump is interestingly a relatively
smaller and smaller piece of that I do
want to play this clip for you Donald
Trump I I mean I feel so stupid even
saying this Donald Trump laid out some
policy ideas yesterday in videos of
course he didn't really lay out policy
ideas he basically ranted claimed he
will do things he almost certainly won't
do and continued to tell the exact same
lies that he's been telling for years
we're going to look at Donald Trump now
announcing
a new health care plan and I know that
many of you will say well but David
Trump announced that his new health care
plan was coming out two weeks later than
August of 2020. don't you remember when
Trump said I do remember that I do
remember that we'll look at that clip in
a moment here is Trump now as if he
hasn't ever commented on this for the
last six years and we don't remember or
how many years now eight years as if we
don't remember uh the fact that he's
made these promises many times Trump
says he's gonna come up with a new
health care plan and I know I I know
guys I know when I'm back in the white
house I will establish a special
presidential commission really of
independent Minds who are not bought and
paid for by big Pharma and I will charge
them with investigating what is causing
the decades-long increase in chronic
illnesses I understand big Pharma I
believe better than anybody else right I
know where they're coming from
and then I will ask them to publish
recommendations for how every American
child can have a safe and healthy
childhood there you go so it's going to
be another new idea of what we need to
do on health care now you might remember
that when Trump was running in 2015 and
2016 he famously said he was going to
have a beautiful health care plan to
replace Obamacare the only thing that
Republicans proposed in 2017 would have
led to 24 to 32 million people losing
health care so that didn't go anywhere
and then there was this classic famous
moment during the Chris Wallace
interview in 2020 where Trump said it
was only two weeks away from a new
health care plan for three and a half
years
uh
she heard me yesterday was signing a
health care plan within two weeks right
a full and complete health care plan
that the Supreme Court decision on DACA
gave me the right to do yeah so we're
going to resolve we're going to sign an
immigration plan a health care plan and
various other plans
we will be doing various plans within
the next two weeks none of it ever
happened and Trump is telling the same
lie again and this really starts to get
to Insanity how many times can you fall
for the same lie what was that thing
George W bush said uh shame on you fool
me once shame on you
fool me twice You Can't Get Fooled Again
something along those lines was what
George W bush said and um honestly folks
this is just nonsense nonsense stuff at
this point if you believe okay now Trump
really is going to get the health care
plan done if you really believe that at
this point it's sort of like I've got a
Brooklyn bridge to sell you uh for a
dollar that that's the level on which
we're operating